hi there Steve Kaufman I'm back from
Palm Springs I'm back here in Vancouver
and I'm gonna be working out of my I
call it my tower like Montana's tower
this is the top floor here of our house
you can't see the nice wooden beams
although I could show them to you and
I'm gonna talk about Spanish verbs verbs
for Romance languages I think verbs are
the biggest bugbear so I kind of looked
around at what I had in the office or in
my room here I have a book called
Portuguese verbs you look in it you know
commands imperatives affirmative
imperatives verbs ending in this that
and the other are you know Sarah stark
are pages and pages of irregular verbs
conjunctions verbs expressing desired
document I mean it's very intimidating
and all those different endings having
spent a lot of time trying to learn verb
tables I am convinced that it can't be
done at the very best you can have a
book like this on Spanish verbs keep it
in your bathroom to leave through while
you're on the John but it's impossible
to memorize in my opinion what should
you do again so then I poked in to
Lincoln to see but because I haven't
been studying Spanish recently at Linc
and I saved a few verbs and lo and
behold link connects amongst the
dictionaries that we have access to is
one called Spanish dict calm and it's
amazing you open any verb up and you
will see the conjugation you will see
examples you'll see your brother you'll
see a little video of course you'll see
the meaning and if you do enough reading
in Spanish and enough listening and if
you're attentive to the language and if
you occasionally review you know this
kind of explanation but if you rely
largely on the fact that repeated
exposure and particularly in different
contexts is eventually going to enable
you to get that
that natural sense for Spanish verbs and
if you can master Spanish we should use
the word master because I don't believe
that's a word that applies in language
learning but the more familiar you
become with Spanish verbs the better
your Spanish will become and you won't
have to worry as you go to use a verb is
what is the form of the third person
singular past tense whatever is over
it'll start to come out naturally so my
advice on Spanish verbs is lots of
leading reading and listening if you
happen to be at link select Spanish dict
as your dictionary of choice and even if
you get a quick explanation of the verb
via our user hints or by a google
translate open up Spanish tip and just
every time you come across a verb
quickly review the different conjugation
endings and then don't but don't try to
memorize it and then go back to enjoying
whatever content you're reading and then
of course listen to it so I hope that's
helpful and bye for now
you